hey emma hey josh how are you guys
i feel like i should like curtsy or
something i don't know what to do but
i watched the whole season this weekend
and you guys are both so
absolutely brilliant in these these
roles and emma i mean got emotional
watching it was hard to watch because
it's present day
we know these people so what was it like
for you to watch yourself
as princess diana oh um
oh mental absolutely mental actually
i got yeah i got sent some episodes and
then i tried to watch them on my own and
was
like i can't do this this is terrifying
you're so critical all the time and you
think oh i want to change this i want to
change that
and then i watch it with my flatmates
which is a brilliant idea because
i could also just like basically not
watch and then
and it was really lovely i was so
interested to hear
their take on it because obviously you
can never be objective
and of course they are and so and yeah i
think the thing they said was like
um about her voice they were like oh
you've um
really got her voice which i was really
happy to hear um
but it was it was really i am proud of
it i'm really proud of what we've made
i think it was a very long shoot and
there are so many people involved
honestly so many people and they will
work so incredibly hard
and for me it was a real learning curve
and seeing what it just what it takes
to make something this is
wonderful and so i just feel i feel
proud yeah
we're very proud of you and josh uh
prince charles i learned a lot
let me tell you what is something that
you learned about him that you did not
know before taking on this role
um i don't know an awful lot i didn't
know anything about him before really
um i don't know an awful lot more
i sort of i think he's you know there's
obviously the stuff that we
already know which we sort of touch on
in the series
um but the rest is obviously fiction and
um and so i don't you know i didn't
learn too much i really i found it kind
of amazing
um his love of gardening
i really enjoyed that because i love
gardening and
also um his
his environmentalism he was sort of like
big on the environment
in the 60s when it wasn't cool to be big
on the environment so that's kind of
cool
and beyond that i mean i i i still i'm
none the wiser about prince charles
really it's mostly creation
it's known that the the royals do watch
the show
uh what will it mean for you that prince
charles diana's family the royals
potentially will watch
this season and see your portrayal what
will that mean to you
yeah it's very strange
i think i'd be lying if i said it wasn't
quite daunting but i
kind of i feel like if they switch it on
if they go to netflix and click play
then
they know what they're getting
themselves into
i don't know i hope that they like
i don't know i hope that there's part of
them that wants to see it i hope that
they're not doing it because they
i don't know are unhappy or something um
but i think
you know as we me and josh often say you
know we are this is fiction
we are playing characters in a version
of events and so i would hope that they
would
not take anything do you personally also
peter's so good at um at giving both
sides of the argument it's never
it's never as straightforward as we're
on no bias
there's no bias it's kind of there's no
playing field and so
it doesn't fear i don't think it ever
feels like we're you know
poking at the uh you know in a negative
way necessarily
congratulations to both of you so so
brilliantly done thank you so much
that was so quick thanks
you